this is our opening session at the
pre-market forum on the international
debt crisis my name is Burt Folsom I'm
the Charles Cline professor of history
and management of Hillsdale College and
on this subject of the international
debt crisis the United States has
unfortunately done its share to
contribute to international debt our
national debt stands at 16 trillion
dollars as most of you know somebody
know what it was a hundred years ago
yeah that's something to ponder a
hundred years ago the u.s. national debt
was roughly 1 billion two hundred two
hundred million 1.2 billion dollars even
allowing and adjusting for inflation
that's a dramatic increase shortly after
that we had perhaps the world's first
international debt crisis world war 1
and the United States national debt
soared to 24 billion dollars and we had
12% unemployment and many of the people
at the time Secretary of Treasury Andrew
Mellon Secretary of Treasury under
Harding Coolidge and Hoover wondered
would it be possible for the United
States to sustain a stable economy with
that kind of debt would our currency be
sound we had high inflation was the debt
simply too high our debt to GNP ratio
too high for us to be able to sustain a
twenty four billion dollar national debt
after World War one the politicians of
the day rated it a major concern
their response to the debt crisis two
points number one cut federal spending
number two cut tax rates when we cut
that federal spending dramatically and
cut the tax rates we increase the
freedom as a result entrepreneurs came
to the fore we get the inventions in the
1920s talking movies radio one of my
favorites the invention of sliced bread
all during the 1920s as a result the
slashing of federal spending cutting
almost a billion dollars a year off that
twenty four billion dollar national debt
all throughout the 1920s cutting the tax
rates by 1923 two years after Mellon
became Secretary of Treasury the United
States had improved and cut almost ten
percent of its national debt and we went
from 12% unemployment to two point four
percent unemployment
today the politicians are viewing the
International debt crisis differently we
have three experts here to talk about
the International debt crisis I will
introduce them and let them give their
talks our first speaker is Eamon Butler
who is director of the Adam Smith
Institute Eamon has degrees in economics
philosophy and psychology received his
PhD from the University of st. Andrews
during the 1970s he was active in the
study of pension and welfare benefits in
fact he worked for the US House of
Representatives for a while and even had
a stint teaching at Hillsdale College
after that he went back to the UK to
found the Adam Smith Institute and in
his work there he is written on Adam
Smith has even helped to get a statue of
Adam Smith in Edinboro he's written on
other economists Friedman Hayek Mises
many of the great economists he's
co-authored a book 40 centuries of wage
and price controls
which is not a story of triumph by the
way Amon contributes to many leading
publications in the UK on issues related
to taxation public spending even health
policy his books include
a book entitled the best book on the
market which I'm sure lived up to its
name
another book the rotten state of britain
another book the alternative manifesto
payments topic today is entitled the
state of the European Union Eamon Butler
thank you very much indeed but Larry was
saying yesterday that Hillsdale goes
back quite a long way and indeed
Hillsdale and I go back quite a long way
because I did indeed teach philosophy
there in the 1970s when I got to
Hillsdale people told me that if you
don't like the weather like there was
probably told wait five minutes well I
have to say I waited five months and it
was still Arctic so I can see why you
want to come to somewhere a bit warmer
to have your meetings but to somebody
who comes from a small island
Texas's almost as confusing as as
Hillsdale because it is so absolutely
vast by our standard and I have a friend
who comes from Texas and he's always
boasting about how big Texas's and he
was telling me one day in Texas we have
trains you could get on a train you
could ride for 24 hours in the same
direction and after 24 hours you'd still
be in Texas and I said well yes we used
to have trains like that but we
privatized them
my friends in the few seconds remaining
I would like to try to make if I have
time six six points firstly just to fill
you in with the background about the the
European debt crisis and the monetary
system that we have secondly to just
review very quickly what has happened
over the last few years which is
Voltaire put it might have put it is a
catalogue of the crimes follies and
misfortunes of mankind thirdly to ask
where we are now
fourthly to ask if there are any
solutions to this debt problem
fifthly to try and predict what comes
next and six late to answer the question
well why should people in the United
States care about this at all so firstly
the background when people talk about
Europe they could talk about many things
there's a geographical area there's the
European Union which is a union of 27
countries there is the European Economic
Area which is slightly larger there is
the eurozone which is a group of
countries seventeen countries which all
have the same currency namely the euro
and that currency was created in 1999
expanded to more countries in 2001 and
the euro was created really as a symbol
of economic unity in indeed a symbol of
political unity in Europe it stretches
from sorry wrong way around
Ireland in the in the West to Cyprus in
the east and from Finland in the north
down to Malta in the Mediterranean so
it's a huge group of countries a huge
area
and because it was a symbol of unity
this idea of post-war unity getting
France and Germany to work together all
the countries of Europe to work together
so we didn't have Wars and in the future
this is so powerful that it was thought
absolutely essential that you should
have as many countries in this currency
union as you could possibly get and
hence of course you have people like
Greece in this union Greece doesn't fit
at all it only got in because it fiddled
its figures we discovered afterwards
that the national deficit the government
deficit was something like three times
what the official statistics Department
in Greece said it was hence we've got
people like Italy in the Union which is
not in such a bad state as Greece but
it's in a bad state and but you couldn't
leave it was just huge France Germany
Italy were sort of founding partners in
the European Union it couldn't be left
out of the currency area so the rules
were just forgotten and all these
countries were were brought in it's
bizarre because the the European the
eurozone is therefore a mix of bizarre
mix of countries which don't really
belong together
there would be more coherence to a
currency unit union that comprised all
of the countries that began with the
letter M or all of the countries on the
35th parallel they they would have more
in common than the various countries in
the European Union but that is the
political drive to make this thing work
so secondly what has happened well as
many people predicted not just me but
Milton Friedman especially when the euro
was first created when there's a shock
that's when things start to fall apart
and in 2007 there were many crises of
sovereign debt certainly United States
had sovereign debt problems we in the UK
having imported all of your subprime
debt I have to say I do congratulate you
on that I mean it was a great American
marketing right you had all this
subprime debt forced on you by the
government of course and you diced it
and sliced it and you sold it to us as
the finest sesumi and we bought it so we
went down when you went down and of
course you've got the the Dubai crisis
and other spin-offs from that so the
countries in the euro zone that we call
the pigs Portugal Ireland Italy Greece
and Spain all the busts key cases
countries started to look extremely
shaky because of the the national
sovereign debt crises and in 2010 Greece
simply could not pay its creditors
national debt was coming up for renewal
and it simply didn't have the money to
pay it so
the eurozone had to get together it's
the the European Central Bank which is a
bit like the Fed here had to come in and
bail out Greece even the IMF was called
in so countries who are not in the euro
zone like Britain and indeed America
find themselves paying for the
profligacy of places like Greece a
little later the European Central Bank
had to buy Spanish and Italian debt in
order to save them from soaring interest
rates those countries are much much
bigger than Greece you know Greece's
Greece could go and nobody would really
notice but Italy Spain these countries
are huge countries you can't that they
are too big to fail if you like and we
found that Italy was downgraded by
Standard & Poor's the eurozone set up a
permanent rescue fund so that it could
carry on bailing out countries when they
failed even that of course has been
downgraded by Standard & Poor's because
it's supposed to have 500 billion euro
to help bailout countries that need need
a fix in fact those are all pledges and
io u--'s from countries including a
number of countries that need a fix
themselves like the United Kingdom so it
got to the point where even France was
being downgraded by Standard & Poor's
aye aye sir I'm British I can't talk
octave Li about France it would
it would they are deep in debt they are
a big mighty economy founding rock of
the European Union and yet I think
wouldn't it be wonderful if they were
the ones that actually brought the whole
thing down I do get a certain
schadenfreude from that I shouldn't
admit it so I think what we've got in
Europe is actually an old-fashioned
balance-of-payments problem you've got
surpluses in the productive countries
like Germany Finland Netherlands and
then in the basket-case unreformed
countries you've got deficits and you
know just to give you an example when I
say unreformed I mean unreformed I
thought Britain was good at bureaucracy
I mean we gave the world the post office
for goodness sake and a lot of people
know this but in 1812 the British
government appointed a man to sit in a
house on the White Cliffs of Dover with
a telescope aimed at France and his job
was to ring an alarm bell if he saw
Napoleon coming well we didn't actually
abolish that job until 1947 but Greece
Greece is even worse in Greece a text
demand is purely advisory there's no
point in paying it because you're
probably going to be retired at 35 on a
full pension anyway so you know what's
the point it's it's it's completely
sclerotic country so thirdly where are
we now well as I say I think we're
muddling but not necessarily through
Greece has indeed defaulted its
creditors took a 50% haircut on on the
debt money is flooding from the club
medicine countries into Italy and Spain
and so on people are buying property in
London they're buying they're putting
their money into German bank accounts
rather than
Italian and Greek bank accounts so
things are just getting worse and worse
you've got 23 percent unemployment in
Greece you've got 25 percent
unemployment in Spain and these
countries have no stomach therefore for
a greater doses of austerity they should
be cutting their budgets but with people
25% of the population unemployed the
trouble is you're getting riots and
civil unrest when you try to do anything
sensible so Europe is growing at a rate
of about zero in fact it's worse than
that because the public sector continues
to grow but it's the private sector is
actually shrinking falsely what's the
solutions to this well one solution is
that you could have as well as a
European monetary system you could have
a European fiscal system attacks and
welfare union to balance the monetary
union just as you have in the United
States if if the Chinese invented some
new form of energy and the price of oil
half tanned everybody in Texas was
unemployed welfare dollars would flow
from Washington down to Texas until the
Texans could get themselves back on
their feet and developed new industries
and so on we don't have that in Europe
and we don't have it in the eurozone but
a number of people who see the euro as a
political objective of Greater Union
would very much like to see it Germany
doesn't much like the idea because
Germany will end up paying for the
profligacy of the Club Med
countries and they feel like Alfred the
Great
felt in in England when it was occupied
by the Vikings that if you keep paying
the Dane gelt as if it's called
you'll never get rid of the Dane and in
Europe we think that the Germans think
that if they keep paying paying the so
called pigs they're going to be in the
mire for some future time
and Germany also has an inflation fear
it doesn't want the European Central
Bank to indulge in quantitative easing
like the Bank of England and the Fed
have done they have this visceral fear
of inflation many of them have lived
through the time in the 1920s when it
was actually cheaper to burn money than
to burn logs because the same volume of
money was actually worth less than the
volume of logs and other countries who
might benefit from a fiscal union are
very suspicious and skeptical as well
because they feel that what will happen
is the big tough countries like Germany
will set the tough rules and tell them
they have to reform they have to cut
their public sector reduce their taxes
cut their debt do all of these good
things which they don't actually want to
do they just want to carry on as before
so there's very little enthusiasm for
anything which might actually solve the
problem so my fifth point what's what
comes next well in the midst of life we
are in debt and I think we're going to
remain in debt for some time
Europe is searching for what we in
Britain call a fudge fudge is Asian and
what we want or what countries in the
euro zone want is they want a way of
making Germany pay for all of these
sclerotic countries without actually
having to reform themselves so they want
Germany to pay but they want to carry on
as they have done before with generous
retirement and a huge public sector and
all the earth all these other things and
I don't think they're going to really
find a way to do that so what we have is
an endless cycle of crises where a
government cannot pay its creditors
european central bank and other agencies
step in
they cobbled together some agreement the
markets fallback in relief and then
three six months later another country
can't pay its bills and the same thing
happens again but no fundamental cure
there is nothing on the table which is
actually going to settle settle this so
it's like a game of poker where the the
the stakes get higher and higher and
you're deeper and deeper in and you
can't you can't get out of it
it's as you've probably realized I don't
know anything at all about economics
I'm just here I think to add to the
proceedings a little bit of European
well class actually and so I've already
given you the the Savile Row glamour and
easy charm so let me quote some classic
poetry samuel taylor coleridge Rime of
the Ancient Mariner there's a very
haunting verse in it like one that on a
Lonesome Road does walk in fear and
dread and having once turned round walks
on and turns no more his head because he
knows a frightful fiend doth close
behind him tread we're a bit like that
in the eurozone the leaders of the
eurozone who see it as a political
agency for European Union cannot look
back again because that'd would admit
that there is a fiend of their own
creation behind them which is about to
devour them they dare not do it why
should you care about this no is it like
as Neville Chamberlain said of the
Sudetenland when Hitler Marx marched in
well it's a faraway place of which we
know little is Europe a faraway place of
which you know little well the UK the US
banks are highly exposed to the UK the
UK is highly exposed to North European
banks North Korea but European banks are
exposed to the South European banks
indeed they've been told under the basel
arrangements to treat the
these sovereign debts as being extremely
safe which they're not so it's you know
your neck bones collect connected to
your shoulder bone or whatever it is so
you are connected in this and similarly
trade has frozen in Europe because
nobody knows where this is going
so again your big trading partners with
Britain him in particular it's going to
affect America and at every stage I
mentioned the IMF at every stage the
European Union is trying to do what
Churchill did in the war which is is
coupling in the war we wanted America to
be in the fight because America had the
resources to do it we didn't and the
European Union eurozone leaders feel
exactly the same they want America and
indeed Britain and other countries that
are not euro members to be there in in
the fight it was Churchill of course
where I think lady astor i think it was
said to church hated churchill and said
the churchill mr. Churchill if I was
your wife I would poison your coffee and
Churchill said madam if I was your
husband I would drink it
and I feel that your financial your
financial Coffee is being poisoned by us
Bob Hope used to say that he liked going
to Washington because it made him feel
close to his money but I think if you go
to Washington now you will find that
your money has already gone and that
actually we in Europe have stolen quite
a bit of it thank you very much
Thank You Eamonn we're gonna have to get
you back at Hillsdale College our next
speaker is richard ron richard is senior
fellow at the Cato Institute in
Washington DC he's also chairman of the
Institute for global economic growth you
may have seen some of his weekly
economic columns from The Washington
Times his column appears in other
newspapers as well he's on the editorial
board of the Cayman Financial Review and
also on the Advisory Board of economics
for the governor of Virginia professor
ron is also a bit of an entrepreneur he
founded the Nova con companies including
sterling semiconductor which is now
owned by Dow Corning but he's a writer
he's written many articles he's taught
at a variety of universities he's
testified before the US Congress on
economic issues more than 75 times he's
a frequent commentator on u.s. radio and
TV he served as an economic adviser to
many leading government officials
including the first president Bush
Richards PhD is from Columbia University
and he's been awarded an honorary Doctor
of Laws from Pepperdine University his
topic today is called the debt crisis in
the United States Richard Ron
even mentioned that he was from the UK
and he was here to bring us class I am
from Florida the opposite but Eamon has
much to atone for because the UK also
gave us Lord Keynes
and some of us have spent much of our
professional careers trying to explain
why he was wrong I look out here and I
see Hillsdale sort of a synonym for
responsibility and I was thinking if you
people were running the US government we
would not have the problem we now do now
I'm sure all of you have no no Americans
who are less responsible some of them
may be your own children but if you
spent 40 percent more than you took in
each year what would happen after a
number of years well people would stop
lending you money for one if you have
had businesses I expect many of you have
had businesses if you spend 40% more
than you take in
year after year eventually you're going
to have a problem
you're gonna go bankrupt well
governments have the same problem
particularly if they don't print their
own money now Greece doesn't print its
own money and it can go bankrupt however
the u.s. does print its own money so the
u.s. cannot go bankrupt in a traditional
sense but we can have very bad or
ramifications I'm gonna go through a few
slides today just to give you some
notion
of where we are and what the problem is
and then my colleague Jim Dorn will
explain how his friends in China and
elsewhere are funding all this let's see
if I get this right okay this gives you
the US federal government debt has a
percent of GDP actually at the end of
World War two our debt was about a
hundred and twenty three percent of GDP
we financed much of World War two
through debt which was a smart thing to
do but what we do at the end of World
War two we quickly brought down
government spending to about 16 percent
of GDP
right now it's about twenty four percent
we we cut tax rates and the economy took
off during the late 40s the 1950s the
1960s and because the economy was
growing faster even though some years we
ran deficits but was growing faster than
the amount of deficit the debt GDP ratio
continued to fall and it fell into
actually under Jimmy Carter it got to
its lowest point in the post-war era
that's because of the Great Inflation of
the Carter era inflation pays off debt
real quickly and I expect all of you
understand that when President Reagan
came in he wanted to increase defense
spending some and he wanted to cut other
government spending and Tip O'Neill
wouldn't let him reduce the spending
rate that he wanted but we did get the
economy growing through the tax cuts and
reducing regulation and the economy took
off and we did fine as long as your debt
GDP ratios less than 50 percent you
really don't have a
and then during the clinton years with
the republican congress we actually ran
surpluses we paid down the debt and
everything was going quite well until
the end of the Bush administration but
remember other Democrats came in in 2006
and that's when the big spending binge
started and people forget that under our
form of government
it's the Congress who appropriates the
money the presidents can influence it
but they don't have that particular
power just just give you an idea of just
the growth in debt here you see this
huge surge for over 16 trillion now
these numbers are so big you can't
relate to them now the CBO always
presents their baseline in their
alternative scenario the baseline is
assuming that all these tax increases
will go into effect the tax increases
will have no effect on behavior I think
you all know better than that
our president doesn't seem to understand
I noticed in the debate the other night
he couldn't understand the difference
between tax rates and tax revenues but
we'll get more into that in a minute
and they always assume in their baseline
that Congress will make these necessary
changes to the entitlement some things
it doesn't happen we'll get more on that
later
okay this is the debt held by the public
I'm just gonna go through these quickly
and here we have the various scenarios
but you can see how this has gone over
the years this is rather dramatic of
showing the kind of deficits and under
President Obama's projections we're
going to run trillion-dollar deficits
for the next few years and he's assuming
that we're going to get a lot of revenue
from taxing those of you who make more
than $250,000 a year you're gonna get a
lot more money out of you
interesting you know if we text you all
view a hundred percent you look all to
me like rich people everybody here's
rich right yeah well okay that's good I
owe you all donate to Hillsdale sure but
let's let's assume that everybody who
made more than two hundred fifty
thousand dollars we took away while we
taxed you a hundred percent
now you could run the government for a
few weeks on that and then that would
stop how much would the government get
from you next year probably close to
zero and that's the thing they always
ignore I was on the board of the Cayman
Island Monetary Authority I was the
first non comedian we regulated banks
insurance companies and mutual funds the
trust companies and so forth and I know
a fair amount about offshore finance I
know that capital can move at the speed
of light and if you if you don't treat
capital well it moves very quickly we
see those things in Europe that Ian that
even just we're talking about we've seen
it elsewhere in a world where a jack-up
attacks and meet at the capital flees
because there's lots of places to put
your money and you're not gonna sit
there and have it heavily taxed the
president was saying spending head and
increased under his watch actually it's
gone up over 22 percent the tarp bill
was put in right at the end of the Bush
administration but most that money was
paid back was blown it had a big surge
of spending was paid back down but
remember the president's famous stimulus
in February 2009 that really jerked up
jacked up the baseline of the spending
and we were supposed to have a 5.3
percent unemployment rate and all these
wonderful things
none of the course occurred because they
were using the wrong model the Keynesian
model and those of us who are
more classical or Austrian economists
have a very different model one it
happens to work this gives you the shows
you federal spending transfers and state
and local spending and how it's grown
over the year the big spike in the 1940s
course of World War two the earlier
spike was the first world war but we
came down quickly after both those wars
but government has continued to grow
it's about 40 percent of our GDP now and
we're getting up there to European type
standards and as even pointed out
they're just doing wonderful by this
this big government here again is just
federal government spending in billions
of dollars put in place adjusted again
as percent of GDP you see you always
have a surge when you go into a
recession growth is the key to getting
us out this chart in a way is key
discretionary spending really hasn't
been growing very much in middle terms
or real terms that's the middle line
there government's gotten bigger but we
are able to control discretionary
spending the Congress has done actually
a fairly good job there you've got
defense all the normal crap the
government does it shouldn't be doing it
first up most of us unconstitutional you
can get a free copy of the Constitution
from the Cato Institute if you'd like
one Jim and I didn't bring enough for
all of you today but it's worth reading
and you'll find the federal government
has very few things that it is legally
empowered to do it does all kinds of
other things which there's no
constitutional basis under our
Constitution the things that the the
federal government there were specific
powers given to the federal
right and everything else was relegated
was the state and local government into
the people and the states can do things
in Governor Romney is absolutely right a
state can put in the health care system
a mandated health care system but
there's no basis for that in under the
federal law our late chairman long-term
chairman of the Cato Institute bill
niskanen former chairman of the Council
of Economic Advisers had done a lot of
studies looking at government spending
and he was hard pressed ever find any
government spending that provided net
positive benefits the cost per virtually
all was greater than the benefits you
have maybe a few exceptions the
interstate highway system I think that's
one that actually paid off but most
government spending is per decade on a
notion of transfers where people get
paid not for doing something
I mean welfare unemployment insurance
you can't get these things if you're a
productive person and so we have these
things built in to discourage productive
activity and so government clearly is a
net drag on GDP in the early or mid
1980s I graphed this out I looked at
countries around the world and I found
as government spending became a bigger
and bigger portion of GDP economic
growth slowed and it's no particular
surprise any of you've ever been around
government know how inefficient it is
compared to the private sector the top
line there is the entitlements and all
this stuff is CBO which is unduly
optimistic and I'll get to that at the
end but the social security the problem
of social security it's predicated on
the notion that you would breed rapidly
and die early and
given how it was first set up a good
number of you should be dead by now to
make it actually sound and you consist
and staying around and the worst people
in terms of Social Security are educated
middle and upper-middle class wealthy
women you live forever and in a way
Social Security is also a bit racist I
used to be on the Social Security
Advisory Commission under Reagan and 82
and 83 and at that point the average
black male only lived to be 63 years of
age unfortunately their lifespans
greatly increased so you had basically
black men paying Social Security and the
typical one didn't live long enough to
get it collected and it was being
collected by older white women not a
particularly good system but that's why
we need to go to a defined contribution
system rather than defined benefit Jose
panera who was also a senior fellow at
Cato along with Jim and myself was the
Labor Minister in Chile who developed
the first were the privatized social
security systems 33 years ago and that
was really responsible for the takeoff
in Chile Chile is doing extremely well
these days and it because they went to a
defined benefits or defined contribution
like a 401k and you really have then the
options to decide what age you're going
to retire and you can save more and if
you want you can pick your own
retirement age some people need to
retire at 50 or 55 they know they have
physical problems others can work well
into their 90's because they enjoy the
work well going to that kind of system
allows this kind of flexibility and gets
you out of the demographic time bomb you
know where a number of biochemist
believe are close to unlocking the key
to the aging system
and that we may in five years or so
actually be a reverse aging I'm thinking
about going back to about thirty five
and that you can ponder what year we're
going to go back to the other big
entitlement program and the biggest
problem is on the health care programs
Medicare Medicaid and so forth we can
fix those we need to have people have
some co-payments we need to be protected
by catastrophic but most people can pay
most of the normal bills but nowadays
what happens if you're on Medicare or a
lot of the insurance programs where
we've got $0 of coverage so nobody goes
in and prices anything now many if
you're having a heart attack or
something you're not gonna go in there
and debate with the doctors about the
price but awful lot of medical
treatments you can price out and we're
having this global medical tourism as a
result this just shows where we are
versus where we could be another example
of outlays versus receipts and you see
the mess we've gotten ourselves in and
these are just show some of the
breakdown on the spending all the stuff
is on you can get just go to CBO gov and
you get most these slides or the
information is all there this one is
important because we keep getting these
forecasts all the Congressional Budget
Office they use static revenue analysis
they don't adjust for behavior and
that's one reason you have such big
differences in the debates between
Governor Romney
President Obama President Obama is using
static revenue analysis
Governor Romney having been a
businessman understands we live in a
dynamic world for those of you have
businesses if you increase the price of
your product the quantity demanded
normally Falls right and so there's only
a maximum price you can reason a tax is
just another price and at some point
revenue will fall and we know that if
you all over taxed to the one hundred
percent government's not gonna get any
revenue the Laffer curve I think you're
all familiar with a capital gains tax
the revenue maximizing rate is under
fifteen percent as of January go up to
twenty three percent well we look at the
CBO forecast you just see how they're
always wrong you know they all show all
it's gonna get better it's gonna get
better and it just gets continues to get
worse and worse and worse I think we're
gonna go off the fifth fiscal cliff in
January because we've got huge tax
increases coming in there's enormous
regulations things are probably never
heard of like FATCA its foreign account
transactions compliance act and it just
rise foreign cap one of the u.s. it's
crazy stuff it puts it puts ten trillion
dollars of capital at risk for maybe a
tax gain of 8 billion nonsense anyway
all this stuff was coming on as january
1st the president a democrat seemed to
be intent upon running this off the
cliff they think somehow you can adjust
their after those of you who are
business people well you have to plan
for the worst scenario too because you
want to survive
and so many forecasters in fact even the
CBO says we may be in a recession in the
first quarter of 2013 at that point
these kind of optimistic things you've
given it were government spending is
only going up to 120 or 150 percent of
GDP will go off the charts
it'll saw very rapid we've seen it
happen in Europe we see it happen of
course in Greece and now in Spain and
elsewhere so we're in deep trouble and I
know we're gonna have discussion on
monetary policy this afternoon by three
really good guys but I just want to
point out what happens if you try to
print your way out what I'm holding in
my hand is the biggest banknote ever
pretty it's some from Zimbabwe it is 100
trillion dollars I'll say it again 100
trillion dollars it's worthless except
for a collector's item it was printed in
2008 the economy collapsed and they had
$2 rise and the Fed seems to have us
ideas European Central Bank - somehow
they can keep printing money the
quantitative easing you're hearing about
business more than printing and you get
away with it for a while but the money
is being sucked out of all of you right
now any of you who are just have money
market accounts or just plain savings
account what are you getting 1%
inflation is running at 3 percent or so
means you have a 2 percent loss there
it's only going to get worse this is a
tax it's a hidden tax we now have the
Federal Reserve taking up fiscal policy
because they are funding government when
they buy government bonds they are
engaged in fiscal activity rather than
additional monetary activity and
unfortunately with I don't have much
time to go through all that but Jim
Doran does so he'll explain it all to
you thank you all very much
thank you Richard
I have a new idea for paying off the
u.s. national debt and we can get change
back from our hundred trillion dollar
bill and buy lunch for everybody at the
free-market forum excuse me you can't
get changed back because we have
unfunded liabilities called Social
Security and Medicare and so forth which
may be over two hundred trillion so you
may need two idiots back to the
International debt crisis in that case
our third and final speaker is James
Dorn and Jim is the vice president for
academic affairs at the Cato Institute
in Washington DC he's also professor of
economics at Towson University in
Maryland now at Cato Jim serves is the
China specialist
he's also editor of the Cato journal
which I know many of you have read Jim
also directs the Cato's annual monetary
conference his research includes the
study of issues like trade human rights
economic reform in China and the future
of money he has edited or co-edited ten
books and that includes a book called
China's future constructive partner or
emerging threat other titles include
China in the new millennium and the book
economic reform in China
Jim's articles have appeared in numerous
publications they include The Wall
Street Journal the Asian Wall Street
Journal
the Financial Times the South China
Morning Post the Hong Kong economic
times investors business daily in the
Australian Financial Review Jim has
testified before the US China security
review commission and the congressional
executive commission on China he's been
a visiting scholar at the Central
European University in Prague also Fudan
University in Shanghai Jim holds the MA
and the PhD in economics from the
University of Virginia his topic for us
today
is called the role of China in the debt
crisis
Jim Doran Thank You Burton I it's a
pleasure to be here I'm a big admirer of
Hillsdale and also my friends at the
Durrell Foundation this free market
forum is a great idea and I'm glad that
Darrell's helping fund it it's a it's a
great place to exchange ideas and to
learn a little bit more market
government and the common good it was
topic of this forum and one thing we can
think about that people are going to
talk a little bit about this afternoon
is the importance of sound money Richard
just pointed that out he could have also
pointed out on this bob wave currency
Mugabe on earlier notes had put an
expiration date which is the worst thing
to do if you have a hyperinflation
because people spend it even faster and
then of course what he did is he put
wage price controls on him blamed the
inflation on the shopkeepers instead of
the government so we see this all the
time
happening over and over again property
rights are important as Larry aren't
pointed out last night
and property rights and our money is a
very important property right to
maintain a stable value of the currency
I'll be talking about a little bit about
what China does with its monetary policy
today my topic is the the role of China
in the u.s. debt crisis
initially they asked me to speak on the
role of China in the debt crisis but
China doesn't have much to do with the
sovereign debt crisis in Europe and also
I could just make one point I don't need
to make 10 or so we can't blame China
for our u.s. debt crisis it's made in
Washington in fact it's very nice to get
outside the Beltway and get outside
Washington once in a while Washington's
the only place I can think of where if
you go to Lover's Lane you see people
hugging themselves
in terms of the broader topic of this
conference I just published a paper that
might interest some view in the Cato
journal which I'll plug which I had it
then editing it now for 30 years they
started when I was 10 years old
but it's on the scope of government in a
free society and I'm a big fan of James
Madison just like Larry iron and
actually I cite some of the things that
Madison said on his famous essay on
property which is a brilliant essay it's
it's only a several pages long but it's
just brilliant so what I want to do
today I'll start off a little bit about
talking about the US debt crisis but not
much since Richard covered that ground
and then I want to talk about China
because China does enable us the US
government the federal government to
grow far beyond what it could otherwise
do if China weren't willing to buy up
you know more than a trillion dollars
worth of our debt that's an unintended
consequence of the Chinese buying of our
debt and China buys our debt primarily
because they run big surpluses and they
have to do something with the dollars
that they get they can't invest them in
the private sector too much in the
United States there's it's it's tough to
get into the u.s. especially if you're a
Chinese investor if you're state-owned
enterprise there might be security
issues I see President Obama just the
other day is prohibiting Chinese company
from running a wind farm and Oregon
because it's next to a military base
that makes drone drones I can't see how
windmills affect that but who knows but
you get into those situations the u.s.
gross public debt the gross public debt
is the is the net public debt plus inner
agency government debt like Social
Security has it has a so called trust
fund there's no real assets in it but
there's i/o use there and they say well
we owe it to ourselves well that's
ridiculous
future taxes are going to have to be
increased to cover this debt so I like
to look at the u.s. gross
debt which in 2001 was six trillion and
as Burton pointed out it's now sixteen
trillion that's a ten trillion dollar
increase in about a decade which is
enormous so the gross public debt is is
right now more than a hundred percent of
GDP and that doesn't count the unfunded
liabilities that Richard pointed out my
colleague Jagadish Buckley has done a
very serious research on this and he
estimates that the unfunded liabilities
and Social Security and Medicare alone
are well over a hundred trillion dollars
what that means is that we need a
hundred trillion dollars or more today
to pay off all expected future promises
over and above taxes collected and we
don't have it so that and Congress is
just kicking the the ball down down the
street and you know these problems are
weighing heavily on us and on future
generations the large increase this
large increase in the US debt over a
decade or so a large part of that
increase has been funded by foreigners
especially China which holds about we
don't know exactly but about 1.2
trillion in US public debt but we should
recognize it's that's only about 8.2
percent of the total u.s. debt that's
held of course no matter who holds the
debt whether private US citizens hold
the debt or the Chinese or some other
foreigners hold the debt u.s. taxpayers
have to still pay it back or fund it at
some point in the future
of course the cause of the US debt
crisis is well known its overspending
explosion of entitlements in particular
failure to make tough decisions and the
recession and stimulus spending which
was largely due to failed government
policies in particular housing policies
and also the Federal Reserve which kept
interest rates very low for too long is
doing the same thing now as Richard said
if you have money and money market funds
you're getting about 0.19% or so less
than 1% way less than 1% almost zero so
the Fed basically is in effect making it
impossible for conservative investors or
people that have saved all their lives
to get a decent return in fact there's a
negative return now this is called
financial repression when the central
bank keeps interest rates real interest
rates less than zero this is the same
thing they do in China the Chinese
central bank provides funds basically
for the state-owned banks which operate
by creating deposit and money and so
forth
and these sob ease which I call them
state-owned banks lend to the S lend to
the SOE s the state-owned enterprises
well here we have the Federal Reserve
and sob in effect buying up
mortgage-backed securities now who owns
a lot of these mortgage-backed
securities Fannie and Freddie which RSO
E's state-owned enterprises so the u.s.
is following the path of China in terms
of financial repression in some respects
by the way sir Sam Samuel Britain who
many of you know heard of
wrote an article in The Financial Times
about a month ago arguing that the US
Federal Reserve should engage not just
in quantitative easing but maybe we
should try a helicopter drop like Ben
Bernanke had suggested a couple years
ago to get the money into circulation
faster and I wrote a letter to the
Financial Times saying this was a bad
idea Zimbabwe's tried it so I got a lot
of respect for Sam Britton but I don't
know where he got that idea from the
Federal Reserve by the way is a big
purchaser of Treasury debt now it bought
77% of net new Treasury debt in fiscal
year 2011 let me repeat that 77% the
Federal Reserve the central bank so what
the central bank is doing is basically
monetizing the debt now it hasn't led to
inflation yet because the Fed pays
interest on excess reserves and the
banks are holding a lot of excess
reserves but if those things come into
the system we could see a lot of
inflation China uses a large part of its
massive three point four trillion stock
of foreign exchange reserves it holds
three point four trillion of foreign
exchange reserves to buy US debt it uses
a big chunk of that as I said about one
point well more than one point two
because that doesn't include the agency
debt that they buy
chyna in effect they're running these
big trade surpluses current account
surpluses and then they're using this to
buy US government debt they're actually
China is actually a net exporter of
capital a net exporter of capital but
China is a capital pork country it
doesn't make any sense it's a waste of
capital they could use that capital much
better in the private non-state sector
in China so just as we're doing during
our stimulus program China had a massive
stimulus program it's empowering the
government and the state is drawing
relative to the market and that's that's
not a good thing so I would argue that
you can't blame China for us prophecy or
for the subprime crisis but China's
policy of financial recession that is
interest rate controls keeping real
interest rates negative they have
controls on deposits and also on loans
although they're relaxing those a little
bit they have a pegged exchange rate
system it's not a fixed exchange rate
system as you would have under the gold
standard it's a pegged exchange rate
system the government pegs it and it
undervalues the exchange rate they have
capital controls so there's no capital
freedom they have the SOPs as I said the
state-owned banks there's a lack of
investment alternatives for individuals
so they either go into the housing
market take undue risks it's probably a
big bubble in the housing market in
China and they have a few alternative
investments
stock markets like a casino over there
and you can't trust any accounting
statements just like in the United
States right
now the paper that I wrote for this
conference I think will be available on
the Hillsdale website but let me just
point out that section 1 of that paper
deals with financial repression in China
and its impact on the u.s. debt crisis
the second section deals with
rebalancing that needs to occur to limit
government power and increase economic
freedom and the rebalancing is not just
you know economists say the rebalance is
China China saves too much the US
doesn't save enough China needs to save
less and consume more as if savings is
hoarding and so forth savings is not
hoarding savings is a decision by
individuals to trade-off present for
future consumption and those funds go
into the economy to generate real wealth
over time and they help not only that
person that's investing but the economy
as a whole and therefore other people
and this ideas savings is hoarding as a
Keynesian idea and it's a dangerous idea
because then the government has to come
in and fill the gap if savings is high
consumption is low the government has to
come in invest in China it's what they
do fixed investment China is huge
through the government and in the United
States the government has to come in and
spend more money run deficits and so
forth so it's a very dangerous idea the
rebalancing that really needs to take
place is not between consumption and
investment government spending all that
it's between individual freedom and the
role of the government the government is
too heavy-handed and the individuals
need more freedom and to be left alone
and I'm going to show in a few minutes
at China in ancient China Lao Tzu and
other philosophers in China writing well
before Adam Smith had this idea of what
they called Wu Wei which is a principle
of non intervention or you could call it
the principle of freedom and if the
ruler would just leave people alone they
said people would become prosperous of
themselves
Thank You President Obama so loud sue
had had had had this idea
symma chen who was a famous the great
historian in china also basically had
this idea as other chinese did they lost
sight of this and of course mala wanted
to destroy private property dong shell
ping came along around 1978 and started
china on a path towards liberalisation
and we should applaud that and since
then the standard of living has
increased dramatically for the average
Chinese person people in China have a
lot more economic freedom and hence
personal freedom than they had 30 or 40
years ago but they still are a long way
from what you know from a free society
obviously the third section of the paper
deals with problems with China's attempt
to build what they call harmonious
society
huijun Dao apparently came up with this
term but his idea of a harmonious
society is top-down whereas Lao tzus
idea of a harmonious society was
bottom-up just like Adam Smith
spontaneous order in fact I'll show you
a slide in a few minutes a picture of
Adam Smith in China
they they had a statue of venom Smith in
China before they had it in in Scotland
Bob Barrow was over in China six or
seven years ago and he told me that when
he who was at school fee the
Southwestern University of finance and
economics and chungcheong-do that he saw
a statue of Emma Smith so I emailed
somebody over there and he sent me a
photo of it and eventually we had that
president of the university come over
the Cato Institute and present us with a
statue of Adam Smith from China which I
thought was probably pretty pretty neat
the last section of my paper deals with
the reforms needed in China and the u.s.
to achieve harmony and lasting peace and
prosperity and both countries have to
address their own problems China is a
convenient scapegoat but we have to look
at ourselves first so I just tell my
brother you know see the see the log in
your own eye before you see the speck in
mine you know sort of and it's you know
it's easy to look at somebody else and
see problems but and I've got a twin
brother so identical he's actually a
liberal attorney by all means uh up in
Buffalo something happened there
someplace I think what happened is I
went to the University of Virginia and
he went to the University of Buffalo for
Law School
I'm working I don't know
alright well let me go through a couple
slides here this quote is is obvious
that the u.s. debt is not sustainable
the Richard pointed that out it's it's
incredible when you look down the road
to see where we're headed
talk about a fiscal cliff you know we're
going down the Grand Canyon in a short
period of time unless the course has
changed this slide again shows fiscal
projections CBO's projections if you
look at CBO forecasts the forecast
errors are huge over time because they
can't predict what real economic growth
is going to be they can't predict what
inflation is going to be they use static
analysis and so forth as Richard pointed
out and when they talk about the
baseline and they talk about a cut in
spending it's not a cut at all as as you
know president pointed out yesterday the
language it's a misuse of language is
not a cut at all if maybe a slowdown in
the rate of growth but the baseline is
still going up so if you use the
baseline projections and you know we we
don't go along with the Bush tax cuts we
increase taxes we use sequester now if
the sequester is a bad idea to begin
with because it's across-the-board cut
there are there are areas in government
that shouldn't exist at all from article
1 section 8 in terms of what the
legitimate functions of government
should be and we could start with the
Department of Education
Hillsdale is a good example of that so
let's cut those illegitimate functions
out of the federal government get back
to safeguarding persons and property
there's not too many people in
Washington however that want to preach
that
so they're not really cuts at all and if
you look at the alternative scenario
you'll see it just skyrockets
so this graph just again shows the two
scenarios a baseline is the the blue and
the red is the alternative scenario as I
said China can't be blamed for the debt
crisis it's due to overconsumption it's
due to an entitlement mentality you know
Richard pointed out that our friend Jose
Panero who's at the Cato Institute he
privatized social security in Chile well
he said that changed the mentality in
Chile once they had a private system
they didn't have to rely upon the
government for their retirement they
were much more independent and they
wanted to have more and more markets and
more exchange in less direction from the
from the top down the United States
going I'm afraid the opposite direction
with entitlement mentality I talk to
people that are pretty successful
actually and they still think the
government owes them a living when they
retire you know they'd be much better if
they would have saved themselves in a
401k had a defined contribution program
and reinvested in through the market
then taking a political risk of waiting
for the government to take care of them
if you look you don't even get social
security statements anymore they haven't
sent him out for a while but a couple
years ago when I received one it said
there was a little asterisk and it said
we may not be able to pay all these
benefits we may only be able to pay
about 70 percent so that's a political
promise in nestor v fleming the supreme
court case said we have no property
rights and our Social Security benefits
so the politicians can do just about
whatever they want and I don't think a
lot of people have thought clearly about
that George Bush's idea for an ownership
Society was a very good idea
unfortunately he wasn't able to
articulate it very well to say the least
it's too bad
Jose pannier I had dinner with him at
his house with Ed Crain and they gave
him a lecture on what was going on in
Chile
and Jose took his pocket he's got a they
get these savings pass books in Chile
that tell him how much they have in
their accounts and President Bush wanted
a copy of that so he took Jose's copy
but unfortunately didn't get any further
than that okay I'm running out of time
so let me just I want to go through a
couple things here let me just skip over
this stuff here Milton Friedman was in
China with us back in 1988 he was
treated like a rock star
that's in gen'l'men square these slides
will be on Hillsdale site too I guess
Skippy's this is go back one so this is
the same from Lao Tzu he says I take no
action and the people themselves are
transformed I engage in no activity and
the people themselves become prosperous
I think that's a great great way to
think of spontaneous order some of Chen
said when everybody works willingly at
their at their trade things will appear
unsought and people will produce them
without being asked that is commanded
sort of a capital freedom this was
written you know 206 BC during the Han
period
system natural Liberty you all know that
quote from Adam Smith's great quote
there's a statue in China it's a
detestable Mao Zedong his pitcher is
still on the currency and during the
Cultural Revolution all these things and
millions of millions of people were
killed and so forth and dong shall ping
this is mal you sure
who won the Milton Friedman award this
past spring at Cato presented every two
years
Mao you sure unlike mild say Tong mal
you shoot argued to take Miles pitcher
off the currency and he got a lot of
death threats and everything else for
he's a very brave man he's in his early
80s and he's still very vigorous there
he is on GQ magazine and a cover in
China skip these that's hong kong in
1938 that's today that's as a result of
free trade and that's what's happening
in China Hong Kong the Hong Kong freedom
virus hopefully is spreading to China a
little bit
I'm sorry have a conclusion already
that's me in my Emperor's uniform it
always impresses my wife so thank you
very much pleasure being here thanks to
our three speakers and we have time for
some questions we have maybe 15 minutes
or so 10 to 15 minutes and we have some
people with the mics here just as a
reminder please wait until the
microphone is brought to you so that
everyone can hear the question you might
give your name and identify the speaker
that you would like to direct your
questions for my name is Preston Jones
and the question is for mr. Butler of
the five countries that you mentioned
Ireland Portugal Spain Italy Greece four
of them are in southern Europe I'm just
wondering do you think that I'm
wondering what you suppose accounts for
that or is that just a coincidence is
there something is other some underlying
cultural things that have led to these
you know particularly fierce economic
problems in these in four of these five
countries to understand that question
yes I think the I think there are
cultural differences I mean if you look
at Italy Italy is really two countries
north and south and if you visit it
the north is industrial is it
industrialized it's it's very what I
would call European you go to the south
I went to a conference in the south and
all the Brits would turn up on time and
all the locals would turn up almost
exactly an hour later and you think
what's going on here but let's you know
that's that's just their idea of time
and it's it's these southern countries
tend to be very agricultural things very
laid-back you know time isn't terribly
important whereas when you get further
north well firstly it's colder and so
you know life is less good you've got to
make your own life you've got to create
things and so on so it's more
industrialized and people have much more
of a sense of
of time and so on the exception is is
Island which is to the west
but again that's always been a very
highly industrialized country and there
may be some some religious differences
as well I mean the the northern
countries tend to be very Protestant and
so they've got a sort of hard-working
ethic
so yes it's a deeply as I say it makes
no sense to have a monetary union in
such a divided group
yes my question also is for professor
Butler my name is Jim aggressed II with
a think tank called just facts we have a
prominent professor in this country who
many of us are hoping will immigrate to
Europe
his name is Paul Krugman and he's a
columnist for The New York Times and
he's been writing in columns as of late
that the limited austerity measures
taken in some of the countries that are
having problems like Spain and Ireland
are deepening the problems just
appreciate your comments upon that yes
well no deal on that one yes I always
say Paul Krugman has offered to donate
his brain to Oxford University but
they're going to contest the will well
they like so many of Krugman's things
there is a grain of truth in it from
which on which he builds a huge edifice
on this grain of sand and yes if you are
in a deep hole and then suddenly you say
right well the government's got a
Slash's expenditure we've got to raise
taxes we've got to balance the books hmm
you're gonna get massive unemployment
you're gonna get massive dislocation and
Krugman and unco say that's unacceptable
even Hayek actually warned about cutting
too deep too quickly our problem is that
we have got ourselves over the course of
well I'm on the decade 15 years we've
been we've been spending wildly we've
had it up a wild party and now we've got
the hangover
you can't necessarily repair all the
damage that has been done in ten or
fifteen years in a couple years there is
an argument you know some people move
Friedman uses a no stop it's don't ed
and then it'll all sort itself out and
Ireland has indeed gone through a severe
austerity budget and they do seem to be
recovering but at huge cost so I think
that what you have to do is to have a
long term vision and be realistic about
it I don't think you should necessarily
say right well it's it's hit the fan
we're going to we're going to slash
everything slash and burn because you
know then you'll have nothing to grow
from I think that what you need is a
long-term vision to say right we are
going to reduce public debt we're going
to reduce the deficit we're gonna reduce
taxation and here's the plan to do it
and it's okay it's gonna take his 10-15
years to get into this problem it might
take seven or eight to get out but
that's our plan the Europeans often
define austerity is government
continuing to spend but higher taxes on
the private sector and so those of you
in the private area should be you should
ratchet down your expenditures and your
well being but those folks in the public
sector well they deserve it people talk
about austerity in Britain but our
expenditure hasn't suffered at all we've
just carried on spending is actually the
same amount and that's but that's called
austerity because we're not we're not
spending right there as we pointed out
the various charts that we all have had
up here government spending in this
country just continues to rise there's
no austerity state local governments
have had to cut back because they don't
print their own money and we've seen
actually reduction in state and local
government employment and some places
have been severe but the federal level
there's been no austerity
thank you all for your comments my name
is Megan Hershey I'm from Whitworth
University and have a question for Jim
Dorn I have been thinking a lot about
Hayek recently in context of this forum
and I'm curious to know how you think I
could respond to the Chinese case hike
makes this argument that economic
liberalisation and political freedom are
directly correlated right but in China
we've seen a great increase in economic
liberalisation but not so much political
freedom since these reforms of dung
shopping and so on so I'd be curious to
know whether or not you think that the
Chinese case undermines Hayek's theory
if not why not
a good question question is again the
argument usually is that economic
liberalisation economic freedom usually
generates political freedom and it
hasn't done so in China well it hasn't
done so by conventional measures you
still have a one-party system with
Communist Party but you got to recognize
there's other changes that have taken
place in China the Constitution for
example has been amended several times
to recognize and give greater protection
to private property rights obviously
they have a long way from enforcing it
when you have judges appointed by the
Communist Party and no independent
judiciary but but now people in China
all own their own private homes that was
not the case thirty years ago they owned
their own private cars they can own
stocks they can travel they can trade
anybody's visited China you can see that
the people have a much higher standing
and they seem happier as a result
because they have more choices so they
certainly have more choices and more
personal freedom even on TV shows and
films and so forth there's there's
areas that they will touch but again
they if they say something against the
Communist Party directly you know
they're in big big trouble but yet
there's you know millions of people on
the Internet they have cell phones and
what they can do they go to Hong Kong
and they can read the Free Press in Hong
Kong they could travel to Hong Kong
freely and Hong Kong they have
demonstrations against the Chinese
government so there there has been
political change and we shouldn't look
for democracy in China what we should be
thinking about is how to limit the power
of the state and I would say that the
power of the government is limited by
economic options when there's more
freedom people have more alternatives
they don't have to work for state
enterprises like they did before 1978
they don't live on communes so these are
all important changes and they don't
have a communist party member in every
neighbourhood telling you what to do
although they have Communist Party cells
the universities and factories and banks
and so on but typically there's a book
that just came out how China became
capitalist by Ronald Coase who won the
Nobel Prize in Economics and by Ning
Wong one of his students you might want
to take a look at that but there's many
books out about how things have changed
in China from a personal standpoint so I
think we have to be careful and not just
look for democracy but to look for a
rule of law developing and more
individual freedom and China has moved
along in that direction but they have a
long way to go
this will be our final question for this
panel
UGL richard directed to you as some of
this can get involved with it
lots of theories lots of evidence about
the causes of the 2008-2009 financial
crisis the basel ii role of Fannie Mae
Freddie Mac low interest rates the
rating agencies would you give us a
theory a statement with some weights the
heart the hard thing to sort out is how
do we wait each of these sorts of things
you can add them to my list but what's
your intuitive weighting of the
different contributors to the crisis I
think that person has done the best work
on this is Peter Wallison over at AEI
Peters had been general counsel to
Treasury during Reagan administration
and he was on the Commission to take a
look at what caused the Great Recession
there was a highly politicized
Commission and he was one of the token
Republicans and he wrote a 116 page
dissent and but he has detailed out I
think in far greater far greater way and
much more objectively and I've seen
anybody else and basically comes down to
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac the Fed
enabled through the production of too
much money the bubble but Fannie and
Freddie
by doing the mortgage-backed securities
enabling that I mean you've got you know
goldman sachs and the rest of them they
took advantage of it
they're no Saints and but they were not
the cause the cause as always was the US
government and US government it did it
through the two government agencies
Freddie Mac and Fannie Mae encourage
them to buy up a lot of these loans from
banks the banks were encouraged to give
of loans to people who couldn't actually
afford mortgages I mean think about most
of us in this room when we got our first
mortgage the bank's actually held the
mortgage
have to go in there and prove you had a
job you're a responsible person and so
forth well then when you could
securitize the mortgages of the banks
could sell them off so as a bank you
don't really care who owns your mortgage
because you're gonna sell it to somebody
else very quickly I just refinanced my
house take care of benefits these lower
rates Fannie Mae now holds my mortgage
it was originated by one of the big
banks but why in the world is the US
government subsidizing my mortgage I
live in Great Falls Virginia I'm not
poor and this is insane policy ninety
percent of all mortgages now in the US
are either owned or guaranteed by the
federal government this is a recipe for
continuing suicide we're not out of the
financial crisis it's going to continue
because we have not let the market clear
let prices fall and the market totally
clear and we're still getting people
into much more expensive housing than
they can afford and when interest rates
start to rise and they will we're going
to have both the disaster in terms of
federal finance and also all these
people in with the low interest loans at
least we're getting away from the
variable loans but people won't be
enough for this it's madness and again I
don't have time today to explain all the
stuff that Peters written but if you go
on the AEI website and you just put in
Peter Wallace and he's done just
terrific work many articles he did a
book I think it was 12 13 years ago
about the coming disaster with Freddie
Mac and Fannie Mae he saw this and
remember he said to me he went from
being considered enough to be in present
thank you Richard thank you to our three
speakers on the international debt
crisis I appreciate their insights and I
hope they can percolate up into Congress
and but at least we enjoyed them today
thank you very much